If it matters it's matter, but if you're anti-matter
I guess you just don't care about anything
anymore.
Wait.
What?
family matters
Matter is everything around us.
It's you, me, the tree, the rock, everywhere!
Even the land, and the ship!
Matter is considered every physical substance
in the universe; if it has mass, it's matter.
But then… there's this other thing called
antimatter.
During the Big Bang, the universe should have
created half-and-half: 1 atom of matter, 1
of antimatter.
But look around you, matter is everywhere.
Where'd all the antimatter go?!
It's one of the great mysteries of physics…
Antimatter is the same as matter -- but opposite.
Scientists have been looking for antimatter
since it was theorized in the 1920s.
Physicist Paul Dirac was trying to reconcile
two new chapters in physics…
Einstein's theory of relativity, and quantum
mechanics.
Think of it this way, when solving for X-squared
equals four, X can be either 2 or negative
2.
Up to this point physicists had spent most
of their energy -- physics joke -- on the
positive solution -- not the negative one.
But since both give you the same result, antimatter
must exist!
Obviously that’s very simplified, but that’s
the idea.
So, if you picture hydrogen, one positively
charged proton, one negatively charged electron:
that is matter.
Balanced.
Simple.
ANTIhydrogen: is made of a negatively charged
antiproton, and positively charged positron!
This evil antimatter twin version has the
same mass, btw.
Experiments with antimatter in the journal
Nature from November 2015 found antimatter
behaves exactly like matter… which is actually
confusing, shouldn't the opposite particle
behave…
I dunno, oppositely?
More research is needed.
The base rule of old physics, is matter cannot
be created or destroyed, but -- sorry old
physics textbook -- that's not strictly speaking
true.
In fact, when an electron hits a positron
they annihilate one another, turning into
energy in the form of gamma rays -- specifically
gamma rays at 511 kiloelectron volts!
To scale that up, if 1 kilo of antimatter
hit a kilo of matter -- based on E=mc squared
the resulting explosion would be 3,000 times
the Hiroshima bomb.
So, new physics, energy cannot be created
or destroyed; because matter and energy are
the same.
Thus, the principle of Star Trek's replicators
and transporters!
Earl Grey, hot!
But this annihilation is a big clue as to
where antimatter went.
We know this annihilation happens because
of particle accelerators.
When high energy particles are smashed together,
or go through beta decay naturally, tiny bits
of antimatter are created.
They clearly want to study this, but they
need to hold onto it, and therein lies the
rub.
Our universe is full of matter.
Whenever scientists create a particle of antimatter,
it hits the mattery walls of the container
and instantly annihilates itself!
How frustrating would that be?
There was literally no way to hold antimatter
in place and get a look at it -- until now.
In 2002, the ALPHA collaboration team at CERN
announced they'd trapped 38 antihydrogen atoms
for 172 milliseconds each.
A breakthrough at the time, but not a lot
of stuff, or a long time.
Then in 2010, scientists trapped hundreds
of antimatter atoms for more than 15 minutes!
Giving them time to explore how these mysterious
things work!
With this study, published in Nature Physics,
as a base, cosmologists believe the Big Bang
somehow created more matter than antimatter.
Not much more… mind you, but more.
A piece in The Guardian describes it as an
"infinitesimally small excess."
Then, in the seconds after the Big Bang -- all
the antimatter and matter annihilated each
other leaving just matter, and creating HUGE
amounts of energy!
Of course, that's just a hypothesis.
So far, the lack of asymmetry-- or the fact
that matter and antimatter seem to behave
exactly the same -- is super confusing for
scientists…
IF there was asymmetry, then they could predict
why the matter survived this great annihilation,
but so far… they don't know; one study is
currently using supercomputers to try and
find any tiny difference between the two.
We'll see.
Otherwise antimatter is dead useful.
Star Trek famously uses it to power spacecraft
-- which makes sense and might actually work
out of fiction, but closer to home, antimatter
could be combined with traditional nuclear
technologies to kick off fusion reactors.
Positron Emission Tomography involves putting
these antimatter positrons into the human
body, knowing they'll annihilate and emit
the predictable 511 keV gamma rays, revealing
tumors and mapping the patient.
1.1 million of these PET scans were performed
in 2005 alone.
And, with a little more energy in the right
place, those antimatter-matter annihilations
could even be used to hyperlocally treat cancer
without harming surrounding tissues!
Matter matters!
But it's not just about matter vs antimatter.
There are also states…
Solid liquid gas, plasma…
And maybe a new one too!
Julia looks into a possible new state
of matter here.
After all this research, I am so PRO antimatter!
But what do you think?
Does it even matter?